- [Shelby] For the first
time in four decades,
the US Army unveiled a wholly
new armored fighting vehicle,
the M10 Booker.
- [Scott] It has a fully
traversable turret.
It is armed with a 105
millimeter main gun.
- [Shelby] Some army
officials have called it.
- A new light tank.
- [Shelby] But many say the mission
and protection of the Booker
is very different from a tank.
Here's how it compares
to tanks like the Abrams,
which the US is sending to Ukraine
and why the army has
invested more than $1 billion
to equip itself with this new vehicle.
The Booker looks very
similar to the Abrams.
Both are fully tracked vehicles
with a four-person crew,
360-degree turret, large caliber main gun
and a commander's
independent thermal viewer
that allows visibility at night
and in multiple directions.
But the Booker is just
over half the weight
of the latest Abrams tank.
- The battlefield role
for the M10 will be to support
deployed infantry forces.
The Booker basically
gives you armor support
that you would not have otherwise had.
It can carry a wider variety of munitions.
It can go places that an
up armored Humvee can't go.
- [Shelby] Tracked vehicles
distribute weight more effectively
for better off-road performance
and the Booker's road
wheels are even lighter
than previous tracked
vehicles of a similar size.
This allows it to move easily
to and around the battlefield,
a common choke point for
heavier tanks like the Abrams.
(chain clanging)
- There will be bridges, for example,
that could support a Booker
but not support an Abrams.
- [Shelby] It also means
the Booker can be deployed
by aircraft relatively easily.
- [Soldier] Rotate.
- [Shelby] For the 31 M1A1
Abrams promised to Ukraine,
delivery could be one of
the biggest challenges.
Only one Abrams can fit
inside this C-17 Globemaster
compared to two Bookers.
But in order to get a
vehicle in this weight class,
the army had to be more strategic
about the level of armor.
Just look at the turret
on the Booker compared to the Abrams.
- [Scott] You can see from the roof
on the turret in particular
is actually armor.
- [Shelby] The turret connects the gun
to the main body of the vehicle.
- The turret front is usually
thought to be the part
of the vehicle that is most
likely to be hit by an enemy.
Abrams' turret is very well protected.
Booker's turret is probably
fairly well protected
but the expectation is not there
that it would be as survivable as Abrams.
- [Shelby] Even with less protection,
the Booker does bring new capabilities
to infantry forces with its main gun,
a nearly 105-millimeter cannon.
(cannon booming)
That's smaller than the Abrams
120-millimeter main gun,
but more powerful
than the 25 millimeter
cannon on the M2 Bradley.
- It gives you the flexibility
of firing projectiles
that are specifically
designed to penetrate armor.
- [Shelby] And the Booker
also comes equipped
with a highly accurate targeting system.
- Essentially, on each of these vehicles,
you have a computer.
That computer can be
used to detect the range
to the target using a laser
and it can calculate where to
fire the gun to hit a target,
including if it's moving and
including if you're moving.
- [Shelby] But less
armor might also explain
a key difference between
the two: engine placement.
- In the case of the
Booker, that would mean
that the engine sits in front of the crew
and potentially provides
additional protection to them.
So if the vehicle is hit from the front,
then there is a chance
that the crew would be more
likely to survive a hit.
Abrams simply just has a
great deal of front armor.
It balances it by having
the engine at the back.
- [Shelby] Compared to the
Abrams' gas turbine engine.
- Burning like 12 gallons of fuel an hour
just to be turned on.
- [Shelby] The Booker's 800
horsepower diesel engine
is meant to extend the fuel
time for a full 24 hours.
- When the vehicle is idling,
it will burn much less fuel.
- All of these factors,
weight, armor, main gun
and engine play into how the
two differ in deployment.
The Booker is not necessarily designed
to go toe to toe with
an enemy's heavy armor.
- Top tier main battle tanks,
adversary armored vehicles
are not what you would want a Booker for.
This is why we have Abrams
and the armored brigade combat team.
- [Shelby] The armored brigade combat team
is considered a heavy force.
The Booker, on the other
hand, is meant to work
with the ground troops or the
infantry brigade combat team.
Military experts say this team is designed
for quick deployment
and is able to operate in
highly restrictive terrain,
like jungles, forests,
mountains, and cities.
- The advantage of infantry
is that they can go lots of places.
They have lots of ability to see things.
They can sneak around more effectively.
If you are fighting in an environment
that has very difficult terrain,
they can then communicate
where the most dangerous
targets are to your tank.
- [Shelby] And the crew
members operating this vehicle
will find it rather familiar
because both the Booker
and the Abrams are made
by the same company,
General Dynamics Land Systems,
so they do share some
features in helpful ways.
- [Scott] We're told that
they have similar controls
for the crew members.
- [Shelby] These shared
characteristics will allow
for more seamless training.
- [Scott] It will be very familiar
to tankers who will basically
use similar crew drill.
- [Shelby] And both the Booker
and the Abrams have
compartmentalized ammunition,
which is a design intended
to protect the crew
if the ammunition explodes.
(ammunition clicking)
This is what helps these vehicles avoid
the jack-in-the-box explosion
seen with many Russian tanks
during the war in Ukraine
where ammunition stored
around the turret exploded,
likely killing the crew and
causing the turret to fly off.
But the arrival of the
Booker comes at a time
when new challenges have arisen
for tanks and combat vehicles alike.
- [Scott] Modern armored vehicles
can be attacked from
literally any direction.
Right now in Ukraine, vehicles
are worrying about artillery
and drones that might
attack the top of a vehicle.
They have to deal with mines
that would attack the bottom of a vehicle,
and of course, direct
fire threats can come
from any direction.
- [Shelby] The army grew
interested in building a vehicle
like the Booker just years
after Russia's annexation
of Crimea with experts noting the need
for more mobile-protected firepower
in light of modern Russian warfare
but actually making the Booker
a reality hasn't been cheap.
Last summer, General
Dynamics was contracted
for the production and
fielding of nearly 100 vehicles
in a $1.14 billion deal
before extending the contract
to include an additional 26 vehicles
and adding another $258 million.
But the vehicle has run into issues.
Early tests found high levels
of toxic fumes when firing the main gun.
- The army has pretty high expectations
of how ready a vehicle should
be when it reaches soldiers.
If there's any issue with soldier safety,
problem with the fumes from the main gun,
which they actually have
dealt with according
to the office that works
the acquisition on this,
they'll have to deal with that
before they can green light production.
- [Shelby] The first unit
of M10 Bookers is expected
toward the end of 2025.
Each of those systems is expected
to cost around $13 million
with plans for the cost to go
down as production increases.
This price doesn't perfectly compare
to the estimated $10 million Abrams
because unlike the Abrams,
the Booker is a new build.
- The difference between
the newest version of Abrams
and the original version
of Abrams is night and day.
(cannon booming)
Abrams literally got a gun upgrade,
a different main gun
installed when it went
from the M1 to the M1A1.
- [Shelby] But this first iteration
of the Booker fills an important gap
in the army's capabilities
and is intended to serve
as a long-term solution.
- When this thing is fielded,
there will almost certainly
be then subsequent changes.
You give a vehicle like
this to a bunch of soldiers
and they will find ways to
break it that you need to fix
and they will find things
to improve about it
that will then go back up through the army
and ultimately hopefully
turn into a Booker A2
that is a better version.
(pensive music)